éditorialiste alexis poulain c'est notre
rubrique l'édito alexis poule à bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors second conseil de défense demain
matin leur confinement est sur toutes
les lèvres
l exécutif consulte les chefs de partis
les partenaires sociaux emmanuel macron
tranches d'ici 24 heures quel est le
risque politique d'annoncer un robot
finement le risque politique est grand
c'est un outil à double tranchant on
voit bien dans cette gestion de la crise
sanitaire que les décisions impopulaires
qui limite les libertés s'accumulent
donc peut-être deux choses la première
c'est pour emmanuel macron de montrer
qu'il est encore aux commandes qu'il n'a
pas totalement tout lâcher face à ce
virus qui semble hors de contrôle et que
en tant que chef de l'état il prend ses
responsabilités et que donc il va devoir
annoncer des mesures difficiles alors le
terrain était préparée par ses
lieutenants vous avez eu gérald darmanin
elisabeth bornes gabriela talent tout le
gouvernement quasiment aujourd'hui qui
s'est succédé au micro pour expliquer
que attention des mesures difficiles
vont devoir être je choisis par le chef
de l'état donc il est un peu préservé
donc se positionner en chef et reprendre
la main sur cette épidémie qui semble
totalement hors de contrôle
le problème c'est que si c'est pour
annoncer évidemment des mesures plus
dures l'imitatrice de liberté encore une
fois ils risquent de chuter de continuer
sa dégringolade dans les sondages il
s'était stabilisé autour de 36%
aujourd'hui les gens se demandent quelle
va être quelles vont être les annonces
et
et là l'exécutif joue gros évidemment
dans ces annonces demain pour les faire
passer à la population on a vu en italie
les italiens en ont marre des mesures
liberticides ils sont dans la rue encore
ce soir à rome il était à milan à turin
ça ne passe plus il se pourrait que les
français et aussi ce ras-le-bol de ces
mesures qui ne comprennent pas alors au
lauzet l'attention c'est hautement
volatile on le disait emmanuel macron va
parler demain à 20h alors à quoi
s'attendre plutôt consignes nationales
re confinement locale qu'est ce qui
coûte politiquement le plus cher alors
tout va coûter cher et pour l'économie
et pour l'image d'emmanuel macron et
pour le pays en général et pour le moral
des français sur la table aujourd'hui
lors des différentes rencontres qu'a pu
avoir jean castex avec les chefs de
partis les idées sont soit d'allonger la
durée du couvre-feu de le faire à partir
de 19h sur tout l'ensemble du territoire
soit un confinement pas alors ce serait
pas un confinement comme en mars
mon inconnue un confinement total mais
un confinement à partir du week end ou
seulement certains seraient autorisés à
sortir pour aller travailler ou les
écoles resteraient ouvertes mais où
quand même une grande partie de la
population se retrouverait à nouveau
confiné une fois encore reste la
lisibilité de ces mesures la
compréhension et l'impact qu'elles
peuvent avoir sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
parce que tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est dans la projection de ce
que pourrait être la courbe de secours
l'un virus de gens qui arriverait dans
les services d'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
la moitié des lits
en réanimation qui sont occupés et la
peur c'est que chaque semaine le virus
soit exponentielle de 30% et qu'on
arrive très vite
au delà des capacités c'est terrible de
gérer cette pénurie au en haut du pic au
mois de mars on avait réussi à ouvrir
plus de 15 min de ranimation
difficilement avec du temps peut-être
qu'il y aura des annonces sanitaire au
delà des annonces qui limite les
libertés parce que c'est pas uniquement
comme ça qu'on peut lutter contre ce
virus et qu'on peut rétablir la
confiance avec les français parce
qu'aujourd'hui je crois que beaucoup de
concitoyens n'ont plus aucune confiance
dans la parole du chef de l'état et
l'exécutif temps la gestion de cette
crise depuis le mois de mars a été
calamiteuse justement alexis le
gouvernement n'at-il pas tiré les leçons
de la première crise clairement pas
regarder ce qu'il s'est passé
lorsqu agnès buzyn quitte son poste à la
santé elle annonce un que le pire est
devant nous rien n'a été vraiment prévu
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de masque
donc les masques étaient inutiles dans
la doctrine proposée par le gouvernement
ils s'en défendent maintenant
aujourd'hui devant les commissions dans
la quête à l'assemblée nationale ensuite
il y a eu des tests le fiasco des tests
très mal faits difficilement fait les
passoires qu'on était les aéroports et
les frontières on a on n'a pas fermé les
frontières là où il aurait dû faire il
aurait fallu fermer les frontières à
l'époque donc des erreurs en cascade des
temps de retard à l'allumage
systématique et un mur au mois de mars
qu'il a fallu gérer avec ce grand
confinement qui a mis l'économie par
terre geoffroy roux de bézieux patron du
medef le rappelait lundi s'il fallait
reconfirmer aujourd'hui les entreprises
n'ont plus la même trésorerie qu'au mois
de mars
l'économie n'est plus du tout dans le
même état et ce serait une catastrophe
pour l'économie française qui ne s'en
remettrait pas cette fois ci même si
elle n'en sait pas vraiment remis du
premier confinement et puis il y a eu
toutes les annonces pendant cet été jean
michel blanquer air qui disait que tout
était prêt ne vous inquiétez pas
emmanuel macron qui le 14 juillet
annonce que si jamais une deuxième vague
arrive tout elle tout est mis en place
dans les territoires les stocks sont
prêts et il n'y aura pas du tout le même
cafouillage qu'au mois de mars
et bien voilà où nous en sommes même
cafouillage voire pire on en est encore
à demander à des à des couturiers et
couturières de faire des sur blues
on manque de matériel médical comme au
mois de mars les tests on en a mais la
fiabilité reste à voir et et est surtout
là où il aurait fallu pérenniser les
lits de réanimation parce que le virus
est là pour longtemps
et bien non on a refermé délit on a
continué les rs ont continué lors de
leur travail de sape de fermetures de
lits d'hôpital de flux et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve avec 5 min de ranimation
peut-être même un peu moins qu'au mois
de mars
il va falloir demander d'ouvrir en
urgence de nouveaux lits de réanimation
alors que même les soignants eux sont en
berne at cette fois ci ne comprennent
plus rien en fait c'est une feuille
totale du système à la fois avec un
exécutif qui est dans une gestion
erratique de cette crise au coup par
coup sans stratégie globale et puis vous
avez tout ce système les ars
l'administration qui ne gère plus rien
qui gère finalement la crise la pénurie
sans avoir les moyens de
prendre le temps et est de mettre en
place les mesures nécessaires donc on
est dans une folie nationale et on va
annoncer demain et macron va annoncer
des mesures encore liberticide
sans plus pour lutter contre ce virus
alors qu'on aurait pu quand même cet été
et depuis le mois de mars préparer
davantage la réponse à cette crise
sanitaire et du coup aujourd'hui
l'avenir de l'exécutif est il en jeu oui
alors surtout la tête de jean castex je
pense ça va être très difficile pour lui
de se maintenir en position surtout dans
l'optique de 2022 c'est un fusible
évident jean castex
il était celui qui a géré le
déconfinement qui est devenue une
déconfiture
il est premier ministre les mesures
qu'il annonce et qu'il a essayé de
prendre avec le gouvernement ont été une
catastrophe depuis le mois de septembre
donc pour lui la position est
extrêmement difficile et puis dans les
sondages il y là il est très très bas
aujourd'hui il n'a jamais vraiment
imprimé dans la population française
quant à emmanuel macron et bien il a
connu des hauts et des bas dans les
sondages aujourd'hui il tourne autour de
36% de gens satisfaits de son action
c'est très peu pour un président de la
république c'est toujours un peu plus
que françois hollande à une certaine
époque un peu plus que lui aussi
rappelez-vous en décembre 2018 au pic de
la manifestation des gilets jaunes il
était à 23 % seulement de gens
satisfaits de son action
donc il peine il était à la peine ça va
être extrêmement compliqué pour lui et
surtout on a l'impression qu'il ne sait
pas ce qu'il fait est que sa parole n'a
plus de valeur entre la promesse faite
au 14 juillet que tout serait prêt pour
la seconde vague est ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on ne peut
pas faire confiance à emmanuel macron et
que quoi qu'il annonce demain les
français vont le regarder de manière
très circonspecte en se disant bon c'est
encore de la com
on va voir il ya une résignation dans le
pays aujourd'hui je crois que tout le
monde essaye de faire du mieux qu'il
peut pour lutter contre ce virus mais
n'attend pas grand chose finalement de
l'exécutif a par un exercice de
communication qui tourne à vide
merci beaucoup alexis poulain c'était
notre rubrique l'édito